if you told zero Colburn your age he
could instantly tell you how many
seconds you'd lived if you asked him to
name the cube root of this he'd be able
to tell you the answer in just five
seconds he did enormously long
calculations in his head within seconds
and then his gift began to fade this is
the sad story of how a boy lost his
genius there was nothing in his
upbringing that could have predicted
this level of Genius zero was born in a
small town of cabot in Vermont on
September 1st 1804 he grew up on a farm
where his father ABIA worked as a
Craftsman to support his large family of
nine children two of whom died after he
settled in Cabot hazira described in his
Memoir which he wrote in the third
person his parents were plain people and
in regard to the early years of this
their son they considered him to be the
most backward of any of their children
Zero's parents didn't think he was very
smart at all that is until one day just
before his sixth birthday his dad heard
him muttering to himself five times
seven or 35 6 times 8 are 48 13 times 97
are
1261. his father was dumbfounded how
could he possibly know all that at just
six years of age with only six weeks of
schooling words soon spread of his
unusual talent and his dad took him
around the country to show off his
skills the president of Dartmouth
College John Wheelock offered to take
Sira under his wing a group of
influential men from Boston offered to
raise five thousand dollars to educate
Zira under their Direction in New
Hampshire
however ABIA rejected their offers
because he wasn't willing to give up
control over Zira ABIA was determined to
find Fame in Fortune abroad at the
expense of abandoning his wife and six
other children
in the spring of 1812 he and
eight-year-old Zira traveled from Boston
to England where newspapers were filled
with stories about his son's peculiar
Talent they made their way to London
where they were greeted by royalty all
of whom were astounded by the boy's
remarkable abilities sadly little
attention was paid to Zira's formal
education the extent of his learning was
the books generously given to him by
these Noble patrons the public who
flocked to see his extraordinary skills
paid a mere one shilling or 22 cents for
admission this was not enough to cover
their living expenses for extra cash his
Dad decided to sell Zira's portrait this
is the only drawing we have of him and
if you look closely there's something
peculiar about it Sierra was born with
an extra digit on each hand and foot he
got the extra fingers surgically removed
they were able to successfully sell this
drawing which led Zira's father to
believe they could also sell a memoir
about his son which would include a long
list of questions answered by but no no
one was really interested in the Memoir
of a nine-year-old even someone as
unusual as him they went to Dublin
Belfast and Edinburgh to see if there
might be more interest there wasn't they
also tested their luck in Paris this was
in 1814 shortly after Napoleon's initial
fall from Power which restored trade
relations between England and France
after showing off his son's skills for
three months in Paris they took a break
and Zira finally started attending
school around this time at the age of 10
his computational speed had slowed
noticeably he took longer to answer
questions than he had in the past he
could have been that his talent faded
because he wasn't regularly
demonstrating his skill in public but at
least he was in school he studied at the
prestigious Royal College of Henry IV in
Paris his education financed by the
French government however his father
struggled to cover the cost of the
school uniform 750 leave or 150 dollars
when he returned to London to try to
raise more funds he discovered that his
agent had ripped him off and a committee
of people who had agreed to raise funds
had lost interest upset of the fact that
zero was being educated in France rather
than in England ABIA took Zira out of
the school in France and brought him
back to London in early 1816. Hungary
and poor ABIA approached the Earl of
Bristol desperate for help the Earl
wasn't all that interested in Zero's
mathematical abilities but he did want
the boy to get a good education so we
decided to cover all his expenses at the
renowned Westminster School in London
where Zira was enrolled at the age of
12. but the school curriculum was
centered around ancient languages like
Latin rather than math a stronger focus
on mathematics might have helped him
address his difficulties with complex
thinking and problem solving although he
had a knack for Speedy calculations he
struggled to get to answers that weren't
immediately obvious in light of this he
doubted that he'd have a future in
mathematics contrary to the expectations
of those around him
the Westminster school also took a toll
on his mental health it had a tradition
requiring younger students to act as
personal servants to the older students
one day an 18 year old beat him up badly
after he felt he wasn't serving him
adequately and Bo wouldn't tolerate such
behavior and ensured zero was no longer
expected to play such a subservient role
in the future
zero was supposed to attend Westminster
for eight years however he got pulled
out after three due to a dispute the
Earl of Bristol insisted that his
chaplain a cambridge-educated former
grammar school Master Tudor zero
full-time in the countryside 50 miles
north of London razira had been spending
the Summers ABIA refused and as a result
the Earl withdrew his financial support
which led to zero leaving Westminster
School
with no schooling no funds and now less
interest in zura in London a BL 1-0 to
make a living as an actor zero was 15
years old and hated that period of his
life writing if there be any part of his
life on which she is disposed to look
with peculiar regret as wasted would be
the year that was spent in preparing for
the theater
he preferred tragic rules Over comedic
ones possibly reflecting his life
circumstances he struggled to get gigs
and searched for more opportunities in
Dublin where he'd frequently walk down
to the beach and beholding vessels whose
sails were filling to the breeze Bound
for an American Port his heart would
become sad and burn with desire to be on
the way to his native land
yet his father refused to return to
America he felt however misguided that
better days lay ahead ABIA was perfectly
confident that the hour Drew near when
he should return in a manner that would
be honorable to himself
Zira finally felt good about supporting
himself financially when the British
polymath Thomas Young paid him two
pounds a week to make astronomical
calculations determining the position of
stars a welcome change from showcasing
his math skills or acting just when
things appeared as if they were finally
taking a turn for the better his
father's Health took a turn for the
worse in late 1823 habia Colburn was not
indeed a victim to hard labor of body
but to something more destructive of
Health labor and care of Mind they'd
been away from home for over a decade
with nothing to chauffeur
on February 14 1824 ABIA died of
tuberculosis he was 54 years old
zero knew he could have left his father
and benefited from the support of others
but he couldn't bring himself to do it
fearing the regret he thought he'd feel
while on his deathbed ABIA told zeera it
would be best for him to return home as
soon as possible
on May 25 1824 he set sail from
Liverpool to America returning to his
mother and four brothers and two sisters
whom he had not seen for 13 years
he harbored feelings of resentment
toward those who envied his worldly
travels writing when sometimes he hears
people wishing that they had his
privilege of seeing the world to think
of the price at which he purchased this
privilege would suggest the idea that
they little knew what it was which they
desired throughout this time his mother
Elizabeth had toiled away on the Family
Farm to support her children it was a
hard life and she eventually had to sell
the land and move to a more suitable
place
zero decided to settle in Vermont where
he taught French while also studying at
the University of Vermont
it was around this time that a period of
reflection led him to make a pivotal
decision
feeling a sense of purpose he embarked
on a journey as a Methodist preacher
traveling from town to town as he
believed spreading the gospel was the
highest calling and in his words the
happiest most useful and honorable in
the world
he felt his mathematical gift was a gift
from above writing God was its author
its object and aim for haps are still
unknown
he wondered if he was meant to make
meaningful contributions to science he
wondered if his gift was intended to
bring him into the public eye enabling
him to spread the word of God either way
by adulthood his genius was all but gone
he no longer possessed the remarkable
mathematical abilities that brought him
so much adulation as a child he lived a
normal life and married Mary a woman
from Vermont with whom he had five
daughters and a son after nine years of
serving as a preacher he worked as a
professor not of mathematics but of
languages at Norwich University in
Northfield Vermont he remained there
until he died of tuberculosis on March
2nd 1839 at the age of just 34. the same
disease that took his father's life
Zira did manage to publish his Memoirs
after all in which he reflected on his
life's challenges again writing in the
third person his father paid dearly for
the singular Talent conferred on his son
yet in many ways it was Zero himself who
paid the price as he was never given the
opportunity to nurture his exceptional
Talent I'd love to hear what you thought
of this story let's connect on X I'm at
newsthink the link is in my description
it's heartbreaking to think about what
zero could have become if he had the
right support and resources to nurture
his talent in today's world we are
fortunate to have access to a wealth of
knowledge and tools to help us reach our
full potential one resource which is
free free to try out is brilliant a
website and app where you can learn math
computer science and data science
interactively Brilliance mathematical
thinking course will change the way you
see numbers as you tackle real world
problems involving fractions ratios and
percentages whether you're looking to
brush up on your skills learn something
new or progress to more advanced lessons
brilliant customizes content to fit your
needs so you can solve at your own pace
there are no tests I'd like to take a
few minutes out of my day to sharpen my
analytical thinking skills with their
logic puzzles so invest in your future
and try it brilliant for free for 30
days by heading to the custom link in my
description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people to sign up through my custom link
will receive a 20 discount on Brilliance
premium annual subscription unlocking
all of the courses thanks for watching
I'm Cindy Palm